sept jours cette étape pour ces adeptes
du bitume la reprise de la saison rythme
avec ce rendez vous particulier un
enchaînement de courses au quotidien
pour lesquels certains sont prêts à
venir d'un peu plus loin pour s'aligner
chaque année kelkoo ce cabaret public
mélomane toujours une faillite de
matinée lancé en 1992 les foules et
arpente les routes du sud de la
martinique
et si à chaque début d'épreuve la remise
des maillots des différents leaders
rappelle un certain tour cycliste
ce n'est pas que les simples similitudes
le vainqueur est désigné par cumul des
temps des différentes étapes des
tronçons de 8,9 kilomètres dont un
prologue et en contre la montre
un cocktail qui rassemble
d'indéfectibles fans si si c'est quoi ça
c'est folie que je m'étais offrir aux
courriers comme je vivais dans
l'hexagone et pour moi c'est un honneur
un plaisir d'être de ce challenge avant
le souci c'est beaucoup plus joli
on partait de sainte-anne marais marin
c'est que les lieux publics après le
contre-la-montre idées à d'autres sont
plus après les couteaux diamants ont
fait le show
ils sont 57 au départ cette année dont
10 femmes et de nouveaux adeptes sont
apparus comme on dire fekir ce lillois
se préparer pour une saison de marathon
et semi quand un ami lui parle des
foules et banco lui dit son entraîneur
depuis le nordiste rafle toutes les
étapes
j'aimerais un jour faire du très haut
niveau c'est voir un peu ce qui se fait
savoir un peu ce qui se fait à
l'extérieur aussi là le principe de la
course est vraiment très ludique et très
sympa j'aime bien moins on sent vraiment
que j'allais être dans le dur et que
dénivelé la chaleur je suis arrivé lundi
j'ai fait ma première course hollande il
ya le décalage horaire tout ça donc j'ai
eu beaucoup de mal à gérer tout ça mais
c'est une expérience une expérience
d'une expérience de vie ça me fera
grandir car si les distances se sont
relativement courtes elles n'en sont pas
moins technique
on parle même d' épreuve de montagne
avec du dénivelé est une succession de
côtes
on va dépasser 2 ou non - dans ma tête
c'est padiou scr on est bien bio paris
cette époque 13e il ya beaucoup de
descente après il faut relancer relancer
ça monte ça descend ce et voilà qu'on
descend trop vivre ça au conflit gm pour
noter donc voilà en fait je m'entraîne
deux fois dans
par jour le matin peut-être je fais un
long et l'après midi je fonctionne c'est
pour avoir beaucoup plus de résistance
parce que pratiquement à chaque étape on
est 8 9 kilomètres d'oreilles pour
pouvoir résister et enchaîner les les
étapes
et pourtant ils sont là cette année
encore moins nombreux certes que pour
les dernières éditions mais ils ont
franchi tous les jours la ligne
d'arrivée en leader ou en plus de
peloton mais ne dit on pas mais ça s'est
terminé
et ça paie merci